a major issue during the upcoming Donald
Trump presidency is going to be the
embarrassment of Trump as president on
the world stage
we know that u.s. standing and respect
around the world was in the in the trash
in the toilet call it where you want
under george w bush we know that us
standing in the world has recovered
significantly under president obama and
it turns out that bombing other
countries doesn't gain respect from the
world community no matter what
neoconservative Warhawks like donald
rumsfeld and paul wolfowitz in the
others tell you if you're president now
I predicted much worse under Donald
Trump because the guy's a buffoon of the
highest order right it's very plain to
see to any clear-thinking individuals
and indeed over the weekend on our
reddit discussion forum david pakman.com
slash read it on our facebook page
facebook.com slash david pakman show
many people posting articles and
questions and ideas about now that
trump's election has up become real who
is the leader of the free world now this
is not a literal phrase right the leader
of the free world is a colloquialism
used first during the Cold War to talk
about the US or more commonly the
President of the United States of
America the president of the US is the
leader of the free world and this is to
suggest that among the Democratic
superpowers the United States is the
most powerful and thus the leader of the
United States is by extension the leader
of the free world consensus is already
shifting away from president of the
United States when we think about
President Trump when we think about
president elect Trump swearing on that
presumably Bible or maybe the art of the
deal I don't know what it is Melania
Trump will hold for him to become
president of the United States that it
is not going to be Trump who is the
leader of the free world but rather
German Chancellor Angela Merkel Time
magazine has proclaimed German
Chancellor Angela Merkel to be
Chancellor of the free world after the
election of Donald Trump
the New York Times is now describing
Merkel as the liberal West's last
defender Timothy Garton ash is arguing
that Merkel could now be considered the
leader of the free world
Obamacare may stay or go under
as I told you earlier Russia might play
Trump like a Stradivarius violin or they
might not that remains to be seen Trump
might build a wall or he might build a
fence and tell his supporters that he
built the wall or he might not
he might bamboozle the low information
voters into thinking he made it America
great again or maybe not but a
buffoonish sexual harasser who ridiculed
everyone from disabled people to
overweight women and stiffed his own
workers and contractors countless times
is not going to be seen by the free
world as its leader now you could argue
that the most powerful person on the
planet would be the president of China
because of the size of China and its
economy but whether China is considered
part of the colloquially free world is
sort of under debate so the discussion
on our reddit about this is really good
I encourage you to check it out bottom
line Pat as Trump becomes president of
the US and the u.s. is increasingly
ridiculed by those in other countries as
Russia and China Chinese influence grow
if France replaces Francois Hollande
with for example marine lepen
and they go in an anti EU direction it's
going to become clear that Donald Trump
is not the leader of the free world and
that German Chancellor Angela Merkel may
be but it's very scary that he will
become the most powerful person on earth
usually if you see those rankings Merkel
will rank on there but the top two go
back and forth between the president
United States and the President of
Russia Vladimir Putin and considering
that Donald Trump will have both houses
of Congress on a side and a Preem court
he'll be able to get a lot done and he
will probably be considered the most
powerful person on earth so brazen
though I don't know I don't know about
that
I mean I know that the trumpeters here's
the thing if you tell a trumpeter hey
you know what the world is embarrassed
about the guy you voted in we're now
saying on the Merkel's leader of the
free world or whoever they will say
that's good we hate Europe those
communist sissies they will actually be
emboldened if the international
community shuns Trump that's what's
incredibly dangerous and concerning that
anything like that we saw it under Bush
I think we'll see it exponentially more
under Trump because of the rhetoric he's
used they will see that as a just
vacation for having elected Trump well
it's interesting because the president
United States is still the commander in
chief the largest army on the planet
yeah but I mean these days the most
important thing is diplomacy working
well with each other so in that respect
I'm sure mark will take over that title
I I think there is really no question
about it I'm curious to hear from you
and I I'm not so curious to hear from
the trumpeters but I know they'll
contact me anyway so at least keep it
polite if you can